[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is maya kotaki I'm a product
manager in security and privacy at
Google focused on encryption today we'll
be talking about encryption at rest both
how Google encrypts data by default and
the options that we give you to encrypt
data as a developer on GCP Google uses
several layers of encryption to protect
data first at the hardware device layer
we encrypt hard disks and solid-state
drives with a device level key then we
encrypt data at the storage system layer
let's dive a bit deeper into that to
understand how storage layer encryption
at Google works you need to understand
how Google stores your data for example
when you upload a cat video to Google
it's broken into sub file chunks for
storage and distributed across Google
storage systems each chunk of data is
encrypted with an individual encryption
key so that no two chunks of data will
have the same encryption key even if
they're part of the same Google Cloud
storage object owned by the same
customer or stored in the same machine
this gives us super low-level
cryptographic isolation of data access
control lists ensure that each chunk can
be decrypted only by authorized Google
services using data encryption keys
these keys encrypt data chunks and are
stored with the data chunks themselves
and of course we never store unencrypted
keys on disk in fact the data encryption
keys are themselves encrypted with
another key for storage called a key
encryption key this is commonly referred
to as envelope encryption because one
key is enveloping another the key
encryption keys are stored centrally in
Google's internal key management service
using a central key management service
makes storing and encrypting data at
Google scale manageable and allows us to
track and control data access from a
central point data stored in Google
Cloud is encrypted out of the storage
level using either AES 256 or AES 128 as
a customer you can use our default
Google encryption just by using Google
Cloud we already encrypt your data
stored at rest by default without any
action required from you using one or
more encryption mechanisms for
additional options we offer a cloud key
management service that lets you
generate use rotate and destroy the
encryption keys that you manage you can
also bring your own encryption keys to
the cloud with our customer supplied
encryption keys feature to learn more
read our whitepaper
encryption at rest and Google cloud
platform
[Music]
[Applause]
you